. I mentioned earlier in the program that
there was a really important milestone relating
to Fox News that had been achieved.
And I want to talk about that now.
For the first time ever, Newsmax TV got a
higher rating, a larger audience than Fox
News at a particular point in time.
This has never happened before and this relates
to so many stories and issues that were following.
This story is about the brewing Republican
civil war.
This story is about the growing war between
some Trump and even Trump and Fox News.
And this story is also about the next two
years of political media.
Recall that Donald Trump for the last year,
but especially after the election has started
going after Fox News.
Why?
Because Fox News accurately reported sometimes
that Joe Biden won the election.
That's it.
That's what Fox News did.
That has attracted the ire of the president
and many of his followers.
And Trump started talking about.
Fox is done, you got to watch Newsmax now,
you've got to watch 018 and these channels,
Newsmax and OMON, are so outrageous that they
actually make Fox News look slightly reasonable.
If you watch at certain times of day and we've
talked about how this will have an effect.
And in fact, even at various Trump rallies
when they interview attendees and they are
asked, you know, even Fox News has called
this, why don't you believe it?
They will say Fox News is part of the left.
Now you have to watch.
And Newsmax.
So this is trickling down to more and more
people, this idea that Fox is now part of
the left.
And so this had a real impact in terms of
ratings as well.
This is just one data point, but it's the
first of its kind Monday night in what's called
the demo, the key demographic of 25 to 54
year old viewers.
Greg Kelly reports, which is a show on Newsmax,
had more viewers than the Martha MacCallum
Show on Fox News at the exact same time.
Now, it was a really small margin.
Two hundred and twenty nine thousand two hundred
and three thousand, really small margin.
But it's still a first because prior to the
election, the numbers were not even close
for Newsmax ever.
Now, one thing that remains to be seen is
whether Newsmax grows online.
When Trump mentioned Newsmax, Newsmax got
a ton of YouTube subscribers, like, for example,
they now have one point seven million.
We only have one point one, almost one point
two million.
But in terms of views on about half the days,
we get more views on YouTube than Newsmax
does.
So just because people subscribe doesn't necessarily
mean they're consuming the content.
But even without knowing that this is a huge
media story, because I've often explained
it's not so much that it's the number of people
watching Fox News or Newsmax or listening
to Rush that matters.
It's that they set the agenda for those who
watch and that then trickles down through
the right wing, a sphere.
And with Trump in the White House, Fox News
has literally been setting the agenda.
Something will appear on Fox News and within
minutes, Trump tweets about it.
And it becomes a story for hours or for a
day or two or even four weeks in some cases.
So even though only a few million people might
ever see one Fox News show, it has agenda
setting power.
And that's what might change after Trump leaves
office if Trump starts giving exclusives to
O.J. and a Newsmax, even without huge viewership
on a Newsmax, could start agenda setting for
the right.
And that, again, would be a completely humiliating
debasement of American media and culture.
And remember, Fox News really caught on around
the Bill Clinton impeachment.
Fox News started in 1996.
And then when the Clinton impeachment took
place from 98 to ninety nine, Fox News exploded
and became more like what it has been recently.
In the exact same way Trump's entire they
stole the election fiasco of 20/20 could be
what puts Newsmax and 018 in a similar position
and sort of here to stay in right wing media,
which is really, really scary for me.
It's interesting because it'll be fascinating
to cover this for the next two years.
But for the country, it's terrible.
And the more people that are getting their
news from outlets like this, the worse off
the country is going to be.